영상 중반 이후에 제가 만든 어떤 앱을 만들어야 될지를 질문을 8개를 받고 유형을 선택해주는
그런 서비스가 소개가 되니까 본인이 만들고자 하는 앱에 대해서 어떤 앱 유형으로 만들면 좋을지
어떤 기술 스텝을 사용하면 좋을지를 확인해 보시기 바랍니다.
한번 끝까지 들어보시기 바랍니다.
설명 먼저 들어갈게요.
네 안녕하세요 기술로트 알렉입니다.
바이브 코딩 시작하려고 할 때 서비스를 어떤 형태로 만들지 고민일 수 있는데요.
서비스의 어떤 형태 그리고 어떻게 구성되는지 정도를 한번 얘기를 해 보려고 합니다.
서비스는 크게 몇 가지 형태로 유형으로 나뉘는데요.
일단 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹 웹
이때는 웹은 주로 컨텐츠가 중심인 서비스가 상당히 척합하다고 생각합니다.
웹앱은 사실은 웹과 앱이 사실은 내용적으로 웹이라고 보기에 더 가까운 앱이에요.
지금으로 치면 네이버 앱 정도가 웹앱으로 보여집니다.
네이버 앱 다운 받아서 들어가 보면 웹페이지죠.
웹페이지인데 스마트폰에서 잘 볼 수 있게 화면을 만들어 놨죠.
모바일의 최적화되어서 아예 만든 겁니다.
보통 이런 걸 만들 때는 도메인을 따로 뽑기도 해요.
이런 식으로 해서 이렇게 들어가면 아예 스마트폰 용으로 보이게끔.
그런 목적인 거죠.
웹은 PC에서.
물론 반응형이라고 해서 스마트폰에서 보면 스마트폰 화면에서 보이고
웹에서 보면 웹에서 보이게끔 할 수가 있어요.
그렇게 하는 게 제일 좋죠.
그런데 네이버 같은 데가 왜 그렇게까지 안 하나 보면
사실 반응형이라는 것도 좀 한계가 있어요.
아주 간단한 화면들은 문제 없습니다.
저도 지금 무비 같은 경우는 웹이에요.
이렇게 웹이죠 웹사이트.
근데 이거 모바일에서 볼 때 키가 있어요.
Function 키 F12 누르면 이렇게 보여집니다.
모바일 테스트를 위해서 이것도 아주 좋은 팁이죠.
이렇게 하시면 돼요.
기기마다 이렇게 볼 수가 있습니다.
이렇게 보시면 모바일 용으로 꽤 잘 보이죠.
이거 그냥 반응형이라고 해서
이건 같은 소스인데 반응형으로 만든 거예요.
그런데 이거를 아예 도메인을 별도로 분리하는 사이트 같은 경우는
이 서비스들을 그런 모양으로 스마트폰의 최적화에서 만들려고 한 거예요.
그렇게 만들어서 서비스를 제공할 수도 있고
이 브라우저가 스마트폰이냐 아니면 PC용이냐에 따라서 반응형으로 만들 수 있다.
이런 전문적인 도메인 또는 반응형.
그래서 웹과 웹은 약간 유사하게 생각할 수도 있습니다.
네이티브 앱이다.
그러면 완전히 기기 설치한 앱들이 네이티브 앱이에요.
설치.
그런데 여기서 아까 네이버도 앱이 있죠. 설치되죠.
설치한다고 해서 다 네이티브는 아닌 거죠.
웹 앱이 있고 설치형 웹 앱이 있고
아예 이런 안드로이드나 이런 애플의 API들, SDK를 가지고 만든 앱들
이런 것들이 네이티브 앱이다 라고 보시면 돼요.
네이티브 앱은 대표적으로 카카오톡 이런 거 네이티브 앱이고요.
또 카메라, 카메라 스노우 이런 거 네이티브 앱이죠.
그런 앱들, 약간 유틸리티 성격으로 쓰는 것들은 다 네이티브다 라고 보시면 돼요.
그리고 하이브리드는 웹 기술과 네이티브의 장정을 결합한 형태다.
그리고 이런 얘기도 있어요.
그렇게 결합하면서도 약간 코드베이스, 코드베이스라고 했는데
그냥 코드라고 생각하시면 돼요. 코드를 다수의 OS가 지원할 수 있게 해준다.
원소스 멀티유저라고 표현해요. 원소스 멀티유저. 멀티유즈.
멀티유즈, 원소스 멀티유즈.
하나의 소스로 여러 개. 그러니까 여러 개라고 해봐야 안드로이드랑 애플이에요.
그러니까 애플형과 안드로이드를 한 소스로 만들 수 있다.
네이티브 앱은 별도로 만들어줘야 됩니다.
안드로이드 기반과 그 다음에 iOS 기반을 별도로 따로따로 만들어줘야 된다.
하이브리드 앱은 웹 앱도 있고 그러니까 웹 뷰 라고 하는데요.
지금 웹 앱 느낌도 있고 그 안에 또 어떤 하드웨어를 제외할 수 있는 기능도 할 수 있게끔 그렇게 만들었고
또 하나 좋은 건 원소스 멀티유저. 원소스 멀티유저라는 건 하나의 소스를 가지고
동시에 애플도 지원하고 안드로이드 지원하고 리액트 네이티브가 대표적인 거고
플러터도 꽤 쓴다 라고 보시면 됩니다.
그러니까 콘텐츠는 웹 기반으로 보여지고 그 위치 알려주고 이런 것들은
지도의 위치 정확하게 GPS를 찍어주는 이런 부분은 네이티브 기능을 쓰고요.
리액트로 만들면은 그런 것들을 쓸 수 있게끔 플러터도 마찬가지고
API를 그 리액트나 플러터가 갖는 게 아니고 안드로이드나 애플의 API를
걔가 후출해주는 것까지 역할을 해줘요.
방금 이제 설명들었던 그 앱 타입에 대해서 요거를 질문을 통해서 제가 요거를 한번
유형을 딱 가이드하는 그런 간단한 서비스를 만들어봤는데요.
app.technot.wiki 입니다.
요기를 접속하셔가지고 질문의 답변을 좀 해보시면 돼요.
저랑 같이 해보시죠. 이게 실제 제가 멘토링할 때도 이런 질문들을 했고
개발 초기에 이런 얘기들을 꽤 많이 해요. 그래서 결국 어떤 유형으로 만들지를 정하는데요.
스스로 한번 해보시면 됩니다. 어떤 앱을 만들어야 할까요 라고 했을 때 주제가 있잖아요.
본인들이 만들고자 하는 주제. 이게 주제도 좀 중요해요.
주제에 따라서 어떤 기능들이 들어갈지가 대략 정해지잖아요.
그랬을 때 한번 요렇게 가볼게요.
정보제공 컨텐츠다. 쇼핑.
일단 컨텐츠 간단하게 해보고 요렇게 한다고 하면
이렇게 하고 주요 사용 기기가 무엇일까.
근데 이거는 보통 요새 PC도 되고 스마트폰도 다 되죠.
그래서 둘 다 이렇게 선택할 수가 있고요.
그리고 오프라인에서도 작동해야 되나요. 그런 컨텐츠들이 오프라인에서 되긴 힘들죠.
제가 어떤 것들을 연상하면서 하는 거니까 본인들이 만들 앱을 여기에 답을 주시면 돼요.
전혀 카메라 같은 거 안쓴다. 그런데 어떤 경우는 쓰겠죠. 어떤 앱들은
만약에 시작을 유틸리티 성격이었다. 그럼 이런 때 필요하다고 체크하면 됩니다.
그리고 실시간 기능. 채팅. 요런 거 있으면 좋죠.
알림 필수. 이렇게 하고 예산 시간 정도.
요거는 바이브 코딩으로 유수해 만들잖아요. 그래서 좀 빠르게 접이용으로 갈 수가 있겠죠.
앱스토어 등록. 제가 지금 연상하고 있는 서비스는 스토어 등록까지는 안 해도 될 것 같아요.
회원 결제 데이터. 회원은 좀 저장을 해야 될 것 같고요.
그랬을 때 웹 앱. 이런 웹 앱 형태가 좋겠다.
이게 딱 답이라기보다는 유로한 형태의 앱으로 만들어 가시는 게 좋다.
물론 바이브 코딩을 하면서도 바이브 코딩을 할 때 가이드를 줄 순 있어요.
주도적으로 웹 앱을 만들어줘. 이렇게 갈 수도 있다는 거죠.
여기에는 주로 뉴스. 이런 데이터들 이렇게 할 수 있다는 거고
개발속도 빠르다. Next.js. REIT. 이런 거 추천한다. 버셀 같은 거 이용할 수 있다.
버셀을 쓰셔도 되고 클라우드 플레이어 써도 되고
몇 개 있죠. 그런 것들을 쓰셔서 배포하면 된다.
이런 경우에 적합 배우 해서 이렇게까지 얘기를 합니다.
다른 거 한번 해볼게요.
이번에 제가 연상하는 앱은 약간 카메라 같은 유틸리티 성격이에요.
잘 얘기해 주나 볼게요. 이렇게 업무 생산성.
이렇게 하면 될 것 같고. 드려할게요.
스먼트폰 위주. 생가하는 앱은 스노우 같은 앱이에요.
항상 인터넷 필요는 없죠. 그래서 가끔 오프라인도 되고
인터넷 없이도 되고 싶어요. 유틸리티니까.
그리고 카메라 이런 거 있어야 되고 위치까지 있으면 좋겠어요.
그랬을 때는 여러 개 동시.
왜냐하면 그 카메라로 찍은 사진의 위치도 같이 저장됐으면 좋겠다는 거죠.
제가 생각하는 그런 앱을 생각해보면 이렇게
그러면 실시간 채팅. 이건 됐으면 좋겠어요.
같이 여행 갔는데 사진을 찍고 서로 공유를 해주는데
그 위치의 표시가 되는. 뭐 상상 속에서.
그래서 핵심. 이것도 마찬가지로 저 비용으로 합니다.
앱스토어 등록을 했으면 좋겠습니다.
회원 결제. 결제까지 좀 하면 좋을 것 같네요.
이거는 네이티브 앱이라고 이렇게 해주죠.
그렇죠. 저는 사실 이걸 어느 정도 생각하고 얘기를 하긴 했어요.
이건 카메라 기능이 필요하고요.
이렇게 조금 스마트폰의 여러 가지 기능들을 적극적으로 쓰겠다 라고 하면
네이티브 앱으로 이렇게 되는 거죠.
그래서 간단하지만 이런 식의 유형을 한 번쯤은 고래불만 하다라는 거고요.
안드로이드 ios를 별도로 개발할 필요가 있다라는 거죠.
그래서 이거를 한번 참고해보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 바이브 코딩 시작할 때부터 서비스 유형에 대해서 고민이 많으실 텐데
참고해보시면 좋을 것 같고요.
이런 내용인들이 좀 도움이 되셨다면 좋아요를 눌러주세요.
제가 이런 관련된 영상을 꾸준히 올리도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
구독과 좋아요를 눌러주세요.